so what else have you done today this is
the first thing I woke up that's it oh
really yeah you-you-you prefer to you
prefer to stay to sleep in late when you
can when you're on the road I you know I
try to but I always just get up early
I'm always up early really oh yeah I
don't know why why cuz you kids I do
have kids but I get up before them I go
to bed late get up early have you always
been an early guy I can't really rise
here dude I have I just don't want to
miss out on anything do you sleep well
or no I don't probably not how do you
function so well I think that's
questionable oh really
Hey look the fact is if you're able to
get up and do all your press and you
have to go into bed and get in a couple
hours I'm literally almost don't make
dominant to work everyday because I
[ __ ] hate getting up so much yeah it
is a pain in the ass isn't it yeah
what's your quote unique all times like
specifics when you're on when you're
when you're shooting something you
shooting Vice Principals do you say no
call times before no I should do that
though I don't I don't think about doing
stuff like that I should
that's probably makes sense would you
have that think as you said you're
afraid of like missing out on stuff or
whatever you have that thing of like no
if I tell them that I won't shoot before
this they'll just find somebody else do
it somebody else like I'm there I I just
sleep there on set to make sure that I'm
there available whenever they need me
yeah I used to you know I would once I
had kids I did I was like I didn't like
them waking me up so I needed to get up
before them to do my [ __ ] before they
were what will you do in the morning
like what you want to get done before
they get up
good question I mean literally I was I
will have moments like that like I wake
up for work now like 10 minutes before I
have to just so and the kids still
asleep just so I can have 10 minutes of
just like it's never gonna be this good
all day today would never be as good as
this 10 minutes is right now that's it
but you guys are not selling me on
having a party I think like possibly
getting married or doing something like
can I kind of want to yeah I'm gonna
[ __ ] 49 but the kids thing and
nothing any of you guys say makes me go
that I should do that I think that it
only is for a few years I could then
after they get a little older they don't
really give a [ __ ] if you're awake or
not they're not ya know my kids seven
months old so it's like it
you have to we never kid that young you
have to be attentive to him at every
waking hour it has to be somebody and
now especially because he started moving
around so it's like you just have to
watch him constantly so you can get a
minute where it's like he's not around
or he's upstairs sleeping with my wife
or whatever then it's like yeah this is
this is it this is heaven yeah this is
all that stuff I took for granted before
these kids were right just silence
Kelly's kid is four he's a buddy of ours
and like now that his kid is four I'm
like that's kind of appealing like cuz
the kid is a little bit of a personality
and he's not as dependent on like every
single moment you have to be there like
he could sit there and just watch TV
like that seems okay why don't you adopt
a young African child um I don't think
that my lifestyle is child appropriate
I'm away too much maybe a teenager then
adopt a teenager nineteen year old if
Jim adopts a teenager and he goes on one
weekend away and in a whole apartment is
just robbed when he gets home there's a
young wayward young lady
III adopt a wayward young lady and help
guide her through trouble times that's
what I do I think it's a great idea the
guidance to you dude you do a lot of
stuff your HBO stuff you just you get
picked up season after season I mean
have you what have you worked on
anything that they've said we're not
picking it up because you seem to walk
away when it's right uh you know we've
uh we've tried to produce stuff with
them that I wasn't involved with like
you know writing or acting in that they
have that they've definitely been like
no thanks yeah but uh unless that face
is on it that's it I guess so you know
with Vice Principals like we were we
were gonna be done with east after the
third season and then we wanted to do
vice principal and they were like if you
do one more season of eastbound then
we'll go ahead and greenlight Vice
Principals so I've never heard something
like that from a network that's show of
faith we want so much of you we'll give
you two of these if you give us one more
of those that's incredible it was
awesome it was good and then it just
makes you feel like alright good [ __ ]
movies I'm just gonna do this forever
yeah yeah well you know what thinks the
HBO and all these the all these actors
who never did he's like Nicholson's the
only guy you still don't see on any kind
of television yeah but like even I heard
DeNiro is even doing a series somewhere
possibly for either Amazon or Netflix
like so many legit movie stars are now
doing series because the writing is so
good and you can do what you want
it's true I mean you know look I love
movies I always will and I'll always
want to make him and when there's an
amazing movie it's awesome to see that
and to see it with people but man if you
have to just the stuff we do that source
so sort of niche it's just you get eaten
alive in the box-office I mean it's like
if you don't have something that like
has mass appeal you just are looking to
get trampled and so I don't know I feel
like with this kind of [ __ ] up comedy
I think people are a little bit more apt
to enjoy in the comfort of their own
home then like in a crowded theater and
they can do it in their time too right
like you don't need that weekend yeah
you can do it like oh this the
word-of-mouth is just starting to pick
up and now they go back and watch all
the all the episodes and everything I
just loved it like Vice Principals I
think I was talking to somebody before
has become like Walton Goggins like the
role of his everything he's done so many
amazing like this is like oh my god it's
just a sight I've never seen and it's
incredible it's I mean it's my favorite
version of him he's he's so goddamn
funny and uh you know David Green and
myself had met him years ago and I
always just liked him I always thought
that even in the serious stuff he was
funny I just liked the way he looked how
he would act and yeah yeah so when we
approached him for this I gave him the
scripts and then he called me up like
the next day and just started talking to
me like Lee Russell and it was just
head-on what we wanted it was he just
got it what a risk to take to call the
other actor and start talking like the
care I'd be so afraid to do that because
we good people what the [ __ ] you doing
I support raelia character is so weird
like it's it's this sort of like evil
pseudo gay but not gage it's very sexual
but not even that sight like just really
odd yeah in that was when we were trying
to cast it before we had gone to him and
people were just coming in and
auditioning no one got it I mean people
would come in and they'd push that
character really far they'd make him a
caricature and Walton just had the
perfect like balance of just evil and
yeah and still keeping it funny yeah are
you taking I'm amazed with guys who
create these that you see a script and
they take these amazing these characters
and they just make them alive and it's
not easy to do it all and have you taken
these things like I'm gonna make a
choice and do this character this way
and then the
do it like that's not know you know I
probably should try to push myself
further I haven't had that yet but which
means you make great choices I guess I'm
making good choices but uh but you know
I mean you have to always be prepared
for that for you to come up I mean I
think it's everyone's fears that's
embarrassing yeah like when I was on
alien I thought I was thinking like I
had fears of like I'm gonna show up on
set they're gonna I'll be there with
that whole cast and Ridley Scott will do
the first take and then he's just gonna
point to me and everyone and the crew
will look at me and he'll be like out
first-day-of-school thing you know we're
like you're just you're imagining the
worst-case scenario that like you'll get
there and it will all just fall apart
you know so like when you whether it's
making a choice or you write something
in because you're you're fully creative
behind it like is it nerve-wracking to
see if it lands with an audience like
like an eastbound and down like to me
it's become one of the funniest openings
in a TV show where he's you just hear
Kenny Powers voice and he's in the car
and you assume it's a voiceover or some
kind of narration and then the reveal is
listening is one of like the great
reveals ever like you have to kind of be
in love with that as a reveal like oh
this is gonna be great but do you sit
there like the first time it airs or
premiere or something with bated breath
to be like please like let this land
yeah I mean you always want people to
like what you do but I think if you're
going to like push things this far and
go there you have to ultimately just
sort of be following your own gut
instincts of what you would want to see
and yeah you know and if you follow that
you know you hope that people come along
but if they don't you can at least you
know you can at least like nursery
wounds by saying well at least I did
what I wanted to do is the Will Ferrell
character based on Ric Flair it was you
know we when we wrote that we uh you
know we asked will to do it that I sent
him pictures of the Nature Boy
that's so great I was watching I get to
see an advanced copy of the premiere of
season two of Vice Principals and I
won't give much away but there's this
moment that like
like the funny like to me it was the
funniest thing in the episode as much
stuff is going on in the episode like my
favorite part of the episode is when you
get back to the school and like they're
all celebrating you and there's this
moment where there's this highschool
girl and she's singing to you and he's
the vice principal he's coming back
after being shot so he's being portrayed
as his hero
and the girl like as he's walking up on
the stage she strokes the back of it's
like so weird and inappropriate and like
you have this one more you look back
like what the [ __ ] but the girl is so
earnest about it like of course we
worship I think honestly she did that
completely on her own oh that was not in
the script no just like she was a walk
up on stage like stroking or vice
principal what a risk for the actress to
take yeah to touch the star of the show
like that's a ballsy ballsy move yeah I
mean I did have great man I I loved it I
can't believe that she did that on her
own - yeah she was good real good
and we last time you were you're talking
about it how this is a you shot all the
episodes at once yeah so this has just
been kind of waiting they're waiting for
an appropriate time for HBO to release
it exactly yeah you know we had we had
turned in the last episode of the second
season before the first season had even
aired so we would have been done yeah so
you knew where I was going but how great
is that no focus-group [ __ ] well they
like this more than they like that
that's why it's great because you guys
are doing what you think is funny what
you think is good and what happens is
these places they want to test
everything and see how these people
respond and see how they respond and
they wind up wrecking something instead
of learning funny people just be
creative and funny that was the
hundred-percent what it was about we
were just like we don't want anyone to
[ __ ] with this and we don't want like
critics to have more of a say in this
right should be able to and we just want
to do what we want to do and it'll be
done and we won't be guided by positive
reactions or negative reactions it'll
just be what we plan for was there
anything that like when you find out
okay like whatever we're a month from
now is when season two is coming out was
there anything that you're like [ __ ]
there is stuff I want to change now that
one critic yeah that's funny do you ever
like that right then you wanted to go
back in five on this one no because I
think the people who didn't like it I
don't think are people that I would
probably be capable of making something
that they would like anyway you know
what I mean it's just people they're
guys I just hate you
well I mean I think we always push
boundaries so I think if anyone's too
sensitive I don't think that they're
probably enjoying what we do and so but
you know you have to make stuff for the
people that you know share a similar
sense of humor is you not everybody
right like people who who think
comedians don't have to be dirty I did
you know comedians just don't have to be
dirty that's what I say
f this.c that yeah yeah we don't need it
as opposed to turning cursing into an
art somebody said that about you to the
god D curse is funny yeah and the best
at curse of you're the best at cursing
how many you said it so many some
[ __ ] so sorry but that's a funny
thing to notice that someone can curse
funny cuz it is a part of the language
it is and I've always been obsessed with
cursing at me when I was listening to
like to live crew or easy I mean I just
thought that [ __ ] was so funny all the
curse words those guys would drop and
then I was like you know had memorized
Eddie Murphy's delirious and just
thought I mean in bed like I think when
I was like in fifth grade I mean it was
like stuff I should not have been
listening to it I just loved how all
those guys swore I just I was amazing do
you know it's funny you say that cuz I
would tape record profanity there was
something about the the it was almost
musical like in certain like you ever
see used cars Kurt Russell there's weird
moments like when he jumps up he goes
that's too [ __ ] high I would record
dirty what the [ __ ] is this Rudy any
time a movie had funny cursing in it I
would tape recorded on this [ __ ] ate
on this cassette really and listen back
to all these amazing moments and films
and they were always like moms were
cursing was used properly yeah you know
what like the one that really got me
when I was a kid I loved that beginning
of Goonies when uh when chunk was like
standing against the window as the Copts
race is going by and he just like
smashes his milkshake all
so perfect so frustrated it was just
great there's something about like
cursing that it's like that's real
emotion is [ __ ] and the Bad News
Bears - I mean I mean it's so [ __ ]
awesome how much those kids just go nuts
in that I love it
yeah the Tanner Boyle you know you can
do it that trophy shove it up your ass I
mean that is a memorable we're sticking
up your ass whatever he said but that
was a very very amazing although some of
the things they said they couldn't even
do in the remake no but they were
[ __ ] do it was so funny man but
people want to believe that like kids
cursing nowadays well it's just there's
just no place for it anymore and then
somebody makes a movie like Bad Santa
and it's like people love it yeah kids
cursing is funny because it's what they
do
I mean my five-year-old son like they I
don't know what five-year-olds talk
about when they're together but I can
only assume it's like they share notes
I'm like well this is what you're not
supposed to say this like you know my
son will hear him use curse words all
the time behind our back and I'm just
like lucky he where the hell is even
getting this from yeah my wife's looking
at me like it's you but I'm like maybe
on TV or movies yeah your show I think
that the moment one of them picks up a
curse word I think they share it with
their friends they share the knowledge
you know they pass it around right it's
funny you memorized delirious and and
and and the the song lyrics that that
kind of were impactful John man it was
uh yeah being like yeah to me I was
gonna go start reciting him but now
[ __ ] Luther Campbell I mean getting
what give me get like blown onstage and
rot Broward County and get arrested I
mean come on the [ __ ] 2 Live Crew
those guys were awesome I saw I saw him
in a weird in a documentary Ozzy
Osbourne documentary called don't blame
me and and Luther Campbell is talking
about how much you wanted to do
something with Ozzy I [ __ ] love that
guy yeah just a [ __ ] maniac it's
weird that it seems like people it seems
like people get more sensitive so you
can't have a conversation about what
curse things just funny cursing is just
cool like it's just it's good like
because people get sensitive about it
but then when you can finally get
something out that has cursing in it
like your stuff like bad saying like any
of that stuff you know
like yeah that's funny that's how people
talk yeah more people should do stuff
like that well is there anything worse
though than a euphemism like anything
worse than where a curse belongs and
they put in ass and it's like just
change it but when they say like oh come
on you can kiss my butt like don't say
it
have you seen any of that stuff have you
seen like like pineapple Express for
example but the TV edit row' you only
have to go in and record that stuff and
so like I always just phone that in I
mean no like well we'll get a
sound-alike I'm like just do that then
I'm not coming in here you know well
it's just like I curse like in eastbound
and down the very I think the HBO was
gonna make us do like a TV safe version
of it you know why for airplanes or
whatever and so they brought us in to do
the first episode and it was something
like in 30 minutes it was like 90 the
workload of like you know what but it's
amazing when they when they try to put
the what everyone knows it profoundly is
such a great impact and went and I don't
even mean when you're dubbing it or
doing ADR over I mean like when there's
a TV like CBS when they want to say
something harsh and they have to write
it clean but they want the same impact
is harsh that you got to make a decision
you can't say it like a euphemism for
bro look at our Tatas oh shut up it
seems bad and then like they're in there
does become an art form to it because
even an eastbound we would find that
like well if Kenny says [ __ ]
here then [ __ ] [ __ ] here and
then [ __ ] you here the [ __ ] you will be
funnier if we take the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out right before you yeah you
have to like space the curse words out
you know when it's like a penny worth
award in a song you can't say love three
times I love you You Love Me we shut up
we heard you yeah you have to that's
just a cadence thing you know that's a
joke impact but yeah you do have to
space it out properly or it's gonna be
redundant is there anything worse than
people who don't get that and use the
same word like twice in the same tweet
or twice in the same sentence and
without the impact they just don't they
just don't because I feel like if they
say the second the word a second time
then you'll get it from the first one
yeah now I remember from three words ago
yeah well what's worse they don't
understand that the redundant
isn't they don't know that they've even
been redundant right you know I feel
like I'm losing my mind ever since I saw
this game being losing this gig like
they don't understand the redundancy is
even happening did you do he's found him
down that was after your highness right
it was uh we did the first season and
then we did your highness and then did
the second season after that so when
your highness comes out right which I
still think is I just I mean grossly
underrated because that is a funny
[ __ ] movie that's just another one of
those things I think that's exactly what
you talked about with movies and box
office in the business that people
didn't get it right away from the
trailer yeah so it's like well we're not
gonna take another chance on that do you
do panic at all cuz that's that's before
you've really developed this niche for
doing amazing television so do you panic
at all when you're like oh my god that
was the first like Danny McBride vehicle
in film and it didn't pan out like what
am I gonna do now you know it's like I
feel David Green and Jody Hill the guys
that I always work with you know we talk
about that stuff a lot and it's like
sometimes I feel like when you're if you
are given success or if you have one
that knocks it out it kind of [ __ ] you
up a little bit because then you start
to be like universally accepted and then
I feel like the people who are hardcore
like start to turn their back on you
because once everyone's on board then
you're not as cool I always like those
bands that never have their day in court
you know because then you're like will
it you want to go out and like spread
the word you know right so I feel like
we're we're very comfortable just like
buzzing right underneath the point
because I do feel like it it doesn't
then you know what you're entertaining
the people that really are into the [ __ ]
and there isn't some sort of bleed over
like oh this you know everybody gets
this guy you know I don't know makes it
more unique more yeah but that's a great
point to as to when people all of a
sudden when the band becomes popular all
of a sudden people go who sold out
there's something about entertainment
where we like to feel unique by liking
it yes we makes us feel special that we
like something and then when you like it
I don't feel special anymore a lot of
times it has only have to do with how
entertaining something is and the other
half is how special does it make me feel
because I'm enjoys a really hard
psychology right it's totally true I I
totally believe that and I think like
the music industry is you know without
all the street
and all this stuff I feel like that's
kind of what [ __ ] things up a little
bit was because you know back in the day
if you had a cool CD or a cool album it
was because like you found the record
store I had that deal but now like
everybody has access to everything so it
kind of doesn't it kind of [ __ ] that
relationship up a little bit you know
right like there's no finding anything
because you already have everything yeah
and anyone can get what you have you
know and uh but I think that with comedy
I think the more obscure or the more
universally you know unaccepted things
are I just feel like it gives you a
little bit more of a of a lifespan I
think